this video is brought to you by keeps
[Music]
hey wisecrack michael here you don't
have to own an exploding candle scented
like gwyneth paltrow's nether regions to
know that the self-help industry is
booming
americans seem to be fundamentally
obsessed with the mission of improving
ourselves
we want life hacks four hour work weeks
desert retreats
and i went to the desert to seek answers
and now
and someone to tell us of micro dosing
at the office is okay
is it alec and in some ways teaching
people how to lift themselves up by
their bootstraps has become a celebrity
worthy job in its own right
it's all like laddering up to one thing
which is optimization of self like we're
here
one time one life like how can we really
like milk the out of this
goopiness aside there are plenty of
people eager to help you
milk the hell out of this thing called
life whether it's tim ferriss telling
you that nine tenths of your work week
is unnecessary
so long as you outsource most of your
administrative tasks to third world
secretaries
or any slew of productivity bloggers
promising to somehow quintuple your
productivity overnight with nootropics
now the quest to be a better more
functional member of society isn't
necessarily a bad
thing like i want to improve my sleep
hygiene and to quiet the accidental
dread that hangs over me like a dark
cloud
and i'm really making progress on that
first one but what if the industry
surrounding these kinds of goals has a
lot to do with why we need help
in the first place we'll explain in this
wisecrack edition on self-help
what went wrong but before we continue i
want to give a shout out to this week's
sponsor
keeps i love wearing hats they're pretty
much a part of my identity
you probably feel the same way about
your hair it's something people
recognize and it's probably one way you
express yourself
if you have ever been scared of losing
it then keeps can put your mind at ease
keeps is an affordable hair loss
treatment program that provides fda
prescription and over-the-counter
medication with keeps there's no trip to
the doctor
or awkward pharmacy pickup involved you
can do everything right from the comfort
of your own home
you meet with a doctor virtually and can
get the medication delivered right to
your door
keeping your hair is all about
prevention so the sooner you take action
the more hair you can save
with keeps some men even report hair
regrowth find out why keeps has more
five-star reviews than any of its
competitors and why hundreds of
thousands of men trust keeps for their
hair loss prevention medication by
clicking the link in the description or
by going to keeps.com
wisecrack if you use our link you can
get 50 off your first order
stop stressing and keep your hair now
back to the show before we understand
how self-help went from a very cool set
of ideas that really meant to transform
the world
into a bunch of self-proclaimed gurus
promising to manifest a better you for
just 395 dollars we need to start with
the founding father of the modern
american self-help movement believe it
or not this dude was a
failed car salesman failed actor slash
failed novelist turned ymca public
speaking coach
no really dale carnegie who was born to
dirt poor farmers in the late 19th
century
arguably created the modern american
self-help industry with the publication
of his best seller how to win
friends and influence people now the
book is pretty much what it sounds like
the guidance is all rooted in the idea
that success in business and in life is
primarily the result not of smarts
not even of super hard work but of
personality
though in carnegie's defense he couldn't
have anticipated the rise of
supremely likable mark zuckerberg anyway
carnegie's success wasn't exactly random
it had a lot to do with the times he
lived in
before and during the great depression
from the turn of the century onwards
community ties and religious
institutions were buckling as the
pressures of modernity led to
vast migration into cities leaving many
people alienated and alone without
family or community to turn to people
looked inward instead this inward turn
was also greatly facilitated by the rise
of psychology with
dozens of popular books tying the
emerging fields perhaps dubiously to
all aspects of life there was psychology
and sex life psychology in the christian
day school psychology of fasting
psychology of murder psychology of your
name
but my personal favorite is psychology
of group
insurance carnegie biographer stephen
watts notes the birth of what
sociologist philip reef famously called
the psychological man
who bolstered by the popular craze
sought to solve their problems by
solving their minds often with the
assistance of self-help books
it makes sense if your mom can't give
you reliable bitcoin investment advice
why not trust this best-selling author
this burgeoning field would serve as a
springboard for carnegie to launch his
own philosophy and it worked he would go
on to be named one of life magazine's
most
influential americans and his writing
with all its folksy wisdom and wholesome
anecdotes established core stylistic
elements of the modern self-help book
of course the rise of self-improvement
as a means to unlock your wildest dreams
if anything was a little surprising
given what came
before now the idea of self-help can be
spotted as far back as ancient greek
mentors and nigerian house folk tales
and
ben franklin's self-improvement happy
autobiography but carnegie arose in the
wake of a culture where self-fulfillment
was not exactly a kosher goal
that is he came of age as victorian
america was dying
remember one of the guiding forces of
american culture was
the protestant work ethic meaning you
had to work yourself to
death while not enjoying anything lest
you end up in the bad place
we're trying out the new butthole
spiders huh they're enormous
and in general middle and upper class
victorian values idealize self-denial
i.e not getting laid and not eating that
extra chocolate chip
cookie this culture however imploded in
part due to the ever expanding reach of
mass manufacturing
america went from a producer-oriented
society where you or your neighbors made
everything you needed to survive to a
consumer-oriented society where you and
your neighbors spent all your money
trying to impress one another with dope
consumer goods
instead of constantly repairing and
maintaining the one nice shirt your
mother made you 15 years ago you could
now get cheap and disposable threads
that were cranked out in a factory
over time mass manufactured trinkets and
toys and chocolates and hamburgers and
dishwashers proliferated eventually
america became a place where it was very
easy to blow your paycheck on an
80-piece china set
where millennial grandchildren under no
circumstances want to inherit and store
in their one bedroom apartment
according to historian warren i sussman
while this consumer-happy shift was
happening the western world
simultaneously saw another massive
cultural change
from the victorian ideals of crafting an
upstanding character based on public
propriety stirring morality and a
supreme work ethic to the modern
individualistic idea of cultivating a
great personality
this idealized personality was according
to sussman particularly characterized in
self-help books of the time as
fascinating stunning attractive magnetic
glowing
masterful creative dominant forceful and
various other adjectives i've used on
dating profiles
and carnegie's book promised that
cultivating such a personality was
possible for
anyone even your boring uncle colin this
must have been
ah we're talking it half it for i was
halfway through me dinner
carnegie also called upon a different
movement which wanted to harness your
mind power to improve your lot in life
new thought
basically it was the secret except you
were supposed to tell god what you
wanted most
within just a few decades an
opportunistic reverend spun
mind power into a literal think yourself
rich ethos
carnegie merged these two intellectual
movements in a way that was perfectly
suited for a culture
newly defined by mass consumption and
individualism his methods explicitly
created to help you
yes i mean you advance were perfect for
an increasingly self-absorbed society
his rise also
luckily coincided with the rise of the
corporate management class
people whose very living depended on
well befriending and influencing people
above and below them but that still
doesn't fully explain the phenomenon of
how to win friends
carnegie's biographer stephen watts
credits one more
crucial force for carnegie's massive
success it wasn't just social alienation
it was economic devastation the great
depression left people devastated
financially
and emotionally as watts recounts
americans were almost
universally humiliated at the sudden
onset of poverty they experienced when
the stock market crashed
more than blaming a lack of banking
regulations or reckless speculation for
their suffering
people especially the insecurely middle
class
blamed themselves in this time of crisis
rather than advocating for
revolutionary agitation most were in
favor of the simple
reinforcement of basic institutions as
watts explains these panicked folks
doubled down on preserving a mystical
american way of life and were determined
to seek out their
piece of the proverbial pie and there
was carnegie
promising that his book could help you
rise above your station and succeed in
this uncertain climate
so long as you really wanted to in a
time when people desperately needed the
wholesale support of their communities
and country
watts goes so far as to argue that dale
carnegie
saved the culture of individualism you
can see it from his marketing which was
rooted in ideals of personal
responsibility for success
never mind that plenty of people still
couldn't afford to feed their families
in one ad he cautions prospective
students that
if you have sincere desire to improve
yourself come along but if you haven't a
real urge to improve yourself
save your time and money for no one can
help harsh
and again it makes sense why people want
to read a book about how to ascend to
the managerial class
so they cannot spend all day in food
lines but this mentality also does a
great job at refocusing attention away
from say
the causes of the great depression which
an ordinary person couldn't do much
about anyway
towards the thing you could do something
about yourself
but ironically this egocentrism was
implanted into a philosophy that just
100 years earlier had sought to do the
exact
opposite one that wanted to take the
logic of self-help and revolutionize the
world and not in the corny join in mlm
kind of way because long before carnegie
the foundation of today's self-help
industry was created by a
anarchist well anarchist socialists and
other revolutionary types
see despite its association with 66
dollar jade yoni eggs and 500
online courses the self-help industry
actually has deeply working-class roots
once upon a time in early to mid 19th
century england self-help meant
blue-collar workers collectively helping
one another this was epitomized by
secularist and radical george jacob
holyoke's book from 1857
self-help by the people which like some
of the earlier self-help materials seen
in america urged folks to learn useful
skills they could then employ to help
their communities and fellow working men
writings like these grew out of british
mutual improvement societies
groups where working class folks would
gather sometimes in dingy old garden
sheds to learn
reading writing and arithmetic in hopes
of improving their conditions
born around the end of the napoleonic
wars these groups especially blossomed
during the mid 19th century and
continued to operate through world war
one they were often established by
political radicals and in their heyday
existed in many industrial towns and
villages in england now
these were the same decades when britain
was desperately trying to banish
illiteracy
offering adult education in the form of
mechanics institutes
however such institutes were funded by
middle class sponsors
who mainly saw the schools as vessels
for imposing their own values onto the
working class
and mutual improvement societies emerged
as an alternative education option
even in places where there were plenty
of mechanics institutes according to
harrison
this suggests that workers were
dissatisfied with the institutionalized
formal education perhaps because
students were often not allowed to
discuss politics or religion in class
basically mutual improvement societies
were what harrison calls the working
man's solution to his own educational
needs
the self-help legacy of cooperation
didn't vanish overnight
even in america scholar beth blum notes
up until the 70s
self-help still commonly referred to
groups of people working together to
improve themselves this was epitomized
by the feminist self-help collective
that compiled the book
our bodies ourselves to teach women
medically taboo information about their
bodies that's a
far cry from the self-centered
philosophy of something like
lean in so what does this have to do
with tony robbins and cheryl sandberg
and the thousands of dollars of credit
card debt nexium classes put me in
enter samuel smiles who visited some
mutual improvement societies and leads
and was impressed by their admirable
self-helping spirits
the scottish author and then editor of a
radical newspaper would give them
inspirational lectures about successful
men who had risen up from poverty
eventually
each lecture would become a chapter in
his best-selling book from 1859 called
self-help this officially gave a name to
the fledgling industry that would spawn
a million tim
ferrisses but from the time he first
visited mutual improvement societies in
1845 to the time he published his book
smile's views seemed to have evolved in
the book
the working-class roots of english
self-improvement seem to have merged
with middle class values of
individualism
smiles for his part took the collective
self-advancing ideology he admired and
essentially boiled it down to
individual work ethic going so far as to
caution that poverty could be a great
motivator and
institutional support a great
demotivator it's important to note that
some think smiles rejection of
government aid
is often misunderstood and conflated
with laissez faire conservatism but
either way while his book proved
inspirational for working folks all over
the globe
smiles ideology essentially functioned
as a middle-class reply to workers
demands for better social conditions
he argues that anyone could improve
themselves without the help of the
government
simply if they wanted to in that vein it
arguably implied that working-class
people who remained poor and ignorant
were basically
morally deficient after all they just
needed to try harder to rise in the
ranks by studying arithmetic when they
got home from work right
while the self-improvement methods that
smiles expounded upon
hard work hyperdiligence and frugality
would differ drastically from carnegie's
charismatic approach to getting ahead in
life his book furthered an
individualistic image of self-help that
would prove incredibly salient to this
day
which is how the idea of self-help went
from a collectivist dream of a better
world to essentially an ideology of
personal
betterment spurred by individual
ambition smiles would be a major
influence on orison's sweat martin
author of a shocking 50 or more
self-help books and booklets including
pushing to the front or success under
difficulties martin would become a
central inspiration for one dale
carnegie cementing the transition of
self-help from collective working-class
advancement to an ethos of
manipulate your co-workers so you can
get a raise and buy more
since then self-help has retained this
laser focus on the individual and their
personality frequently in relation to
improving their worth in the labor
market
it's also explicitly sought to help
people adjust to sweeping social changes
like when helen gurley brown counseled
women on how to succeed in a deeply
sexist 1960s workplace or when jane
fonda taught nearly middle-aged baby
boomers how to hang on to the physiques
of their youth
are you ready to do the workout but our
favorite era of late 20th century
self-help started in the early 70s a
time of economic contraction and
widespread anxiety self-help books
emerged with super chill titles like
looking out for number one and winning
through intimidation to urge
just what it sounds like ruthless
self-interest and the gospel of greed
some books had even bleaker titles like
you can profit from a monetary crisis
and
how to prosper during the coming bad
years a kind of blatant appeal to
self-interest amidst widespread
suffering that makes dale carnegie look
almost communitarian in contrast what's
more as scholar mickey mcgee notes
within self-help culture values from the
competitive world of the marketplace
have been
transplanted to the personal world of
intimate life never has this been more
apparent than in the 1980s relationship
advice books that urged women to see
their relationships as a matter of
maximizing profit not cynical at all
and what about today self-help has found
a lucrative niche in helping americans
cope with and surviving an
increasingly unstable labor market and
social climate while victorian advice
books were about being successfully
married and employed today's advice
books are about the struggle to remain
marriable and employable forever in
keeping with the trend of previous
decades
self-improvement books treat the self as
your most valuable commodity
and your primary duty as maximizing its
value
if i can help people feel more in
control of their life
more stable that will minimize
their interest in doing those negative
things
books like you are a badass function as
how to win friends and influence people
for the shitty flexible gig economy
where nobody's labor is particularly
valued and everyone's goal is to become
their own boss via their etsy wooden
wind chime store
self-help has never been more profitable
or more popular
constituting an 11 billion dollar
industry as underpaid workers seek out
new skills and tips in hopes of making
their way up the socioeconomic ladder
many workplaces
especially mlms even employs self-help
vernacular to keep people motivated in
spite of their shitty paychecks with the
right mindset
you can rise above your station or so
the saying is gone since the fateful day
carnegie loaded up his typewriter
but as in the great depression we are
living
in extraordinarily horrible times for
getting ahead
and it's understandable that people
would take advice from these finance
gurus who promised them
unheard of wealth if they follow simple
tips like tape coupons together so
they're worth twice as much
put double-sided tape on your dog's paws
so he picks up quarters when he walks
around the street
and join 10 churches take some money out
of the tide bucket each week
and a lot more where that came from but
as we all struggle to manifest
new mindsets or be more badass or
package your personalities on five
social media platforms it's worth asking
are we like folks during the great
depression turning to self-help because
we blame ourselves for our struggles
rather than blaming blatant
institutional failures like massive
student debts stagnating wages and so on
and
don't get us wrong there's nothing
nefarious about wanting to improve
yourself it's
admirable even and most studies on the
topic even show that people
do find self-help books to be well
helpful but we think it's only healthy
to question something that's become as
institutionalized as the self-help
industry and it's worth wondering
why the message much like carnegie's
back in 1936 remains
if you read this inspirational book and
don't become massively successful
it's because you didn't try hard enough
but what do you guys think
is the self-help industry just trying to
make us better people
or is something a lot uglier going on
let us know in the comments
big thanks to our patrons for all your
support hit that subscribe
button with the force of a victorian
suppressing their libido
and be sure to ring that bell and as
always thanks for watching
[Music]
later
start a religion you don't have to pay
taxes if you start a religion so just
start your own
uh perform a miracle to get people
involved and then just let that cash
roll
in um do we have to stop now i got more